all I'm ever doing is trying to take
empathy gratitude kindness positivity
optimism and create repackaging for it
in modern society to help somebody see
it cuz life is one big game of
perspective you have crazy beautiful
eyes like the first have you said that
to me was like I think it's the first
time we met and it was one of the most
awkward things I didn't know I expect
that from Gary
you did nothing to make that happen
true I always say I can't take credit
for them I said that all the time I
don't take credit for anything I am all
my accolades I'm like my parents yeah my
circumstance ooh
Soviet Russia to America ooh the 80s oh
Jersey oh this Oh some form of learning
disability it may be shitty at school
like right uh you know by the way not
being diagnosed with a learning
disability which then either I'm right
or I'm wrong but it doesn't matter I
didn't have to deal with that pressure
especially the 80s when it was a little
bit more of like scary than it is now
like what if I was what if I did maybe I
didn't probably not because they would
have caught really you get into all
these circumstances this is a big deal
though I'm sure that what I talk about
is right for me because I'm incredibly
in tune with myself and I'm an
incredibly good communicator in a style
that hits a certain group which helps
them get the insight to create
affirmation to create lack of fear to
try something to start the process to
get to a happier place that is a [ __ ]
blessing yeah hundred percent now I want
people to figure out that things are
right for them based on their luck
circumstance what's their beautiful eyes
yeah yes maybe they're not an
entrepreneur because they don't lack
they don't have incredible lack of fear
but maybe that they are incredibly
compassionate unbelievably analytical
remarkably competitive incredibly
gorgeous wonderfully funny like let's
lean into what we're [ __ ] awesome
about everybody spending all their time
or what they suck at you
themselves they're doing that and I
promise you everybody else is spending
all their time telling you what you suck
at I'm spending all my time thinking
about what I'm [ __ ] awesome at yeah
and I'm spending all my time trying to
figure out what everybody else is
awesome at some of its very obvious like
beautiful eyes others are like hey
you're a good [ __ ] kid
keep listening to me
I am stunned by how almost binary my
judgment is completely predicated on
intent mm-hmm if you if I believe your
intent was to be there for me mm-hmm but
your actions were not that you were
consistent
I'm completely unbothered and I don't
know what that means but I'm super
[ __ ] grateful that I have it yeah but
that's an art and a skill that you have
and I'd like to think I have the same
where I'm unable to do that to I'm able
to let go what is the what is the
concept of not having expectations from
your perspective because I would tell
you that that maybe my great superpower
yeah you know somebody said to me Tom
bail you on my podcast said to me Gary
your superpower is your ability not to
judge yourself and I've been saying it a
lot and then literally on a flight this
week I was like right cuz I don't judge
others yes like I'm able to not judge
myself because I don't judge others a
lot of people who are like a lot of
right so tell me I don't know I'm no
powerful no I love that that's that's a
great point how do you that's such a
great point no your your support um
because the reason why we have we judge
others is because we judge ourselves
right the opposite of what you're saying
and so for me it's the same thing the
reason why I don't expect is because I
see everything is my responsibility yeah
I see everything is my work yes and I
see everything else is a bonus yeah it's
just amazing that anyone even cares
about me
or has time for me or makes an effort to
do something or connect me to someone or
whatever it is and that's just a
beautiful bonus of life but I've got to
be in charge of it I think that just
came from many years of having
expectations I think that came from
times when I did expect and I didn't get
and I realized I don't to feel this way
anymore well this gets into parenting
yes you know this is the framework of
what our parents are creating for us
we're one of the most interesting things
that are happening in a lot of modern
societies as we have had
disproportionate prosperity over five
six seven decades America has had a
clean run I mean we've had a couple of
recessions here and there we've had a
couple of internal country scandals we
have underlining issues of sexism and
racism and things that nature but in its
most macro this has been the Empire
things have been good and what has
happened is we've
created unbelievable levels of
entitlement mmm and town entitlement
entitlement I can't stop thinking about
it
yeah it has come it's starting to
consume me hmm that I never you know it
sounds crass like never expect anything
from anyone hmm but but I almost want to
find new ways to say it yeah just to
help people understand it is the great
gift of life
yeah when you get into a place where you
have zero expectations and you actually
don't believe you're entitled to
anything hmm
you can actually start doing things yes
absolutely because otherwise that's
what's paralyzing you because you feel
like somebody else is in control no the
man the society the government the
president and not president the governor
the mayor the system the the systemic
infrastructure and really it's a crutch
right like war really it's just it's not
like that's another wedge force it's an
excuse yes at its best it's a lack of
perspective yeah
[Music]
you talk about so much about the value
of human life yes and how rare it is
amazing it is which I don't know if you
know this but it's like such a deep
vedic concept which is like thousand
life so Vedic is like the philosophy
that I studied it ok one of the oldest
philosophies of man client and one of
the biggest principles in there is about
the value of human life like the the
inflict the way I think about four
hundred trillion correct correct
it's helped so many people by the way
out of all the pieces of content I've
ever put out something in it has
penetrated how does one get like you
when you hear when I hear you say it
when I look at the way I was taught it
when I look at the monks that I know
live it when I know people have really
lived there what was it that helped you
really extract you and live that okay
nice it's my all I'm ever doing is
trying to take empathy gratitude
kindness positivity optimism and create
repackaging for it
in modern society to help somebody see
it cuz life is one big game of
perspective mmm and if you've been
raised by parents in an environment and
have natural DNA that makes you look at
something upside down I've got to flip
it and when I say I got to I have this
enormous love and need for admiration
that I've come to realize admiration
will not come in the form of me making
the most money admiration will not come
in any other form than if I give so much
more to you than I expect from you in
return I was gifted an ability of the
gift to gap I am creative I understand
attention graphs I have work ethic I
have aspirations all of that has created
one big game where I feel responsibility
to be able to get this message out in a
way that won't get to people that can
never become monks or that won't become
disproportionately high educated
philosophical I'm in the trenches with
my style but it's the same [ __ ]
product and so four hundred trillion to
one was one way for me to get people to
be like do you [ __ ] there's nothing any
of us in this room will accomplish that
is even in the [ __ ] galaxy of that we
havin a chance to do
thing yeah I just don't understand what
are you gonna complain about today that
is even remotely close to never having
the ability to have a life look what
what are you gonna complain about like
what's so shitty in your life like
you've got the at-bat even if you're the
worst ranked person seven point seventh
billion in the world you're born to
slavery and genocide in a fifth world
country where you're raped every day
starved slaved lose your parents no love
the game of life actually still creates
the rare potential for you to break out
of that and go on to do something and
then bring positivity to the world
better than not being born it on I
believe that
[Music]
what's the worst advice you're hearing
out there right now that you won't be
able to be more thoughtful about all of
it because it lacks self-awareness
it lacks pushing people into
self-awareness and it lacks context em
anything all advice right now is a
problem including all of mine big it's
why I'm trying to make them make it
about them there's a lot of bad advice
brother like if somebody watches me and
gets fired up to start a business and
there's Sheila meal and can't do a
business they're going down a path of
depression yeah if if they're a if
they're a competitive ambitious person
but they also went to high society
education and right now the push there
is balance and like like hard work is
bad and we become too much of Europe
current Europe I believe this by the way
like that's bad advice for somebody
because they're gonna be depressed
because they lean to move into current
social you know political correctness
and what they actually are is a dog and
they just want to grind yeah but right
now grinding is bad yeah I've seen all
advice is bad if you haven't deployed
enough love for yourself and
self-awareness to understand what to
pick off
you have a video's title the thumb stuff
you buy owns you yes which I love yes
what is the dumbest thing you've ever
bought great question because we've all
bought dumster my my current apartment
in New York City
interesting it made me super not liquid
made me miss out on investing in uber
you know it's the dumbest in literal but
it established my family in a
neighborhood that I wanted to raise it
so it's obviously way better yeah in the
second level you know probably the
dumbest thing that I've ever bought are
the things that I didn't buy right right
like a vacation that I should have taken
which would have been a fruitful Tut use
of time that's definitely a you know but
you guys I'm trying to be a little bit
better in communicating regrets cuz I
can't focus on them so and I wanna talk
about them because I don't want to make
it seem like I'm not human yeah I could
have done a lot more balance of leisure
14 to 30 because I worked every minute
yeah I wish and and when you start with
I wish that is regret I wish I had five
to ten more memories in my 20s with my
high school and college friends of going
on those trips that everybody does like
there's a very interesting clip of me
where you can really see it manifests
where I talk about like I'm not lucky
like a bunch of kids when I first
started blowing up from high school
college would hit me up and I can't are
you so lucky I was like [ __ ] I'm
not lucky yeah when you went to the
Jersey Shore every weekend I worked my
ass off it's not necessarily what I want
to be talking about right now and I'm
trying to get the temperature of society
but it's a very big truth yeah so I
would say that yeah the dumbest things
there's dumbest thing I ever bought for
the things that I ended up not buying
I talk a lot about why people aren't
capable of producing content to the
world which is now the requirement as a
human to achieve happiness I genuinely
believe that I believe taking advantage
of all of our abilities to reach out to
the world through these new channels
with no friction is an enormous gift and
opportunity the reason most can't
achieve it is because they're unable to
take back the inevitable feedback that
immediately comes with the opportunity
to your point I genuinely believe the
reason I can take the feedback is
because when I go into my Instagram post
that I just posted literally and
back-to-back content comments excuse me
one will say that I'm walking on water
and the next will say that I'm a snake
oil salesman Charlotte and the fact that
neither penetrate my psyche is
absolutely where I'm at hmm absolutely
and that's a quite Amity right like that
is that whatever you want to call it
it's the game because people want the
positive reinforcement that you know
there's so many models on Instagram
right men and women you're so beautiful
you look so great you're so beautiful
you look so great you're full of [ __ ]
you look fake they're crushed because
they take too much yeah and that you
look so great yes and I think and I
think that's the point that we're
hitting on here which I love is that
that over emphasis on positive it's what
makes the negative so hard to take it's
also an incredible place for me to add
some clarity that I haven't done a good
job on historically which is something
I'm thinking a lot more about ragga if
it's fun to see you here because we have
this call yesterday I'm like look I'm at
my worst when I'm excited in an
interview and I'm and I'm drilling a
headline yes I love doing it it's fun
it's showmanship it's wrestling promo
videos it's my natural state you know I
talk a lot about not giving a [ __ ] about
other people's opinions it's also
because I take the complete opposite
approach which is every negative piece
of feedback that I get I genuinely go
into two places a I deploy sympathy and
empathy for the person leaving the
comment because inevitably immediately
on that action I know that they're not
in a good place if you go to somebody
else's social consume it and then spew
hate you're not in a fun you're not in a
good place
no here you're unhappy yeah next I start
trying to see the insight to any truth
in it
you know the second that you're high on
your own supply you're vulnerable yes
and so I don't I don't give a [ __ ] about
anybody's opinion ironically I value
everybody's opinion I just synthesize it
and then decide to take the good from it
yes by deploying empathy and sympathy to
the deliver of the I'm stunned by our
lack of conversation society right now
on this part there's a lot of judgment
and heartaches and comments we need to
judge the person delivering the message
absolutely like like how is your
mother's opinion of you have the same
weight as Anonymous 54s comment on
Instagram yeah that is ludicrous
absolutely in the same way of how is a
co-workers opinion you have to factor
that in different than your mother cuz
your mother
blindly thinks you're the best that if
you're lucky enough to have that mother
you know and so it's super fast it's
it's it's just pulling from opposite
directions and I think you know I'm
pulling so hard from opposite directions
that my balance is coming in that look
when I do podcasts like this knowing
that you have such a thoughtful audience
I come on knowing we overlap in a lot of
places all I've been thinking about for
the first ten minutes and I'll think
about for the rest of this talk is can I
bring one person value can I add an
adjective a sentence a saying the same
thing in a different way than J or
somebody else says that helps Karen
who's listening to this right now on her
treadmill like actually do something
there's nothing more intoxicating than
when you're a communicator then getting
the feedback loop of somebody saying you
said something I did something I'm
happier now end of story
[Music]